bienvenue pour ce 7,8 sport pour revenir
sur toute l'actualité sportive de ces
derniers jours sans plus attendre voici
le sommaire de votre hebdo en baseball
tout d'abord montigny le bretonneux
évoluera à nouveau en d1 la saison
prochaine les cougars se sont imposés ce
week-end les images du sacre à suivre
deux défaites en deux matches et des
scores loin d'être serré le club de
rugby de versailles 1 qui est relégué
cette saison en division honneur
l'équipe ne trouvera trouve toujours pas
ses marques
et puis la ryder cup 2007 vient de se
refermer aux états unis mecahers et demi
d'euros était sur place dans le
minnesota nous reviendrons sur cet
immense compétition de golf qui se
déroulera en france à saint quentin en
yvelines pour sa prochaine édition dans
deux ans en 2018 et le golf il en était
question à saint quentin en yvelines où
se tenait la cinquième édition du golfe
estivale un événement pour les habitants
du territoire et pour leur faire
découvrir ce sport souvent méconnu jugé
élitiste
entre découverte du golf national et
parcours débutants les précisions avec
aymeric courteille chargé de projet
événementiel à l'agglomération de saint
quentin au micro de semaine 22 heures
on a eu d'autres événements aussi
s'appeler robin golf où on allait au
centre-ville de saint-quentin à l'espace
saint quentin pour initier le plus de
monde possible au golf et
et en fait on s'est aperçu que faire
venir les gens au golf découvrir
vraiment le lieu l'endroit ça changeait
tout parce que
les gens pensent qu' on n'a pas droit de
rentrer sur un golf de manière spontanée
alors que le golf est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde et cette nouvelle édition
du golfe festival n'a pas manqué de
faire le lien avec la ryder cup en
organisant notamment des duplex avec le
minnesota où se tenait cet événement
ryder cup ce rendez-vous qui oppose les
meilleurs américains aux meilleurs
français tous les deux ans prochaine
étape la france et saint quentin en
yvelines
et pour mieux se rendre compte de
l'impact attendu michael et demi d'euros
étaient sur place et malgré le décalage
horaire mais ds vous l'avez vous tenez
votre place ce soir je roule soir vous
descendez tout juste de l'avion vous ai
fait je vous rappelle tout d'abord le
concept de la ryder cup pour faire
simple c'est l'équivalent de la coupe du
monde du golf le principe les américains
et les européens dispute des matches en
équipe et en individuel pendant trois
jours alors aujourd'hui je ne vais pas
vous parler à des résultats wilfried
vous le connaissez tous les états unis
ont remporté la compétition 17 à 11
après trois défaites consécutives des
européens je vais plutôt vous parler de
l'envers du décor donc justement un des
supporters il y avait trois cent mille
personnes sur ses trois jours de
compétition oui 300 millions de
personnes pendant la compétition pour
comparer un open de france à 50 ans
nîmes il attire seulement entre
guillemets 70000 personnes pendant 1
quatre jours de compétition et on peut
dire que les américains et les européens
ne viennent pas pour faire de la
figuration oubliez tout ce que vous avez
vue sur le golf en france à chaska il
était parfois plus de 20000 sur un trou
pour encourager leurs protégés
les supporters n'hésitaient pas à
chanter et à se déguiser
je sais que vous êtes un fan d'elvis ou
le crime du coup rien vous cacher et
cheikh où je vous propose un petit
extrait le king est toujours vivant le
king est toujours vivant et il était à
chaska dans le minnesota après la
musique on va à présent regarder les
réactions des supporters à propos de la
ryder cup 2016
c'est une pure atmosphère nous ne
pouvons pas la comparer à une ambiance
classique l'ambiance est comparable à un
stade de football
c'est la plus grande compétition le pays
l'un prend très au sérieux et nous
sommes très fiers de cette victoire de
l'indépendant d adapter à nez avec lui
il y avait également des stars à côté
des greens et notamment le basketteur
six fois champion nba wilfried avec les
chicago bulls
vous l'aurez compris c'était un michael
jordan comme on peut le voir à l'écran
il n'est pas passé inaperçu de nombreux
fans l'ont pris en photo et moi aussi
rejoint la wii on entendu les supporters
étrangers
les supporters français il y en avait
alors je dois vous avouer où le fait
qu'il n'y en avait pas énormément j'en
ai croisé 3 pendant la compétition la
raison principale est le prix à chaska
se situe à plus de huit heures de vol
dans le minnesota sans compter le taxi
évidemment le prix des places était lui
de 250 dollars par jour pour suivre la
compétition
beaucoup de français ont dû être
découragés mais j'ai pu rencontrer un
sur le site il s'appelle à martial et
nous vient à de bretagne c'est
extraordinaire je suis vraiment ravi
d'être ici c'est vrai que j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de français je suis même
quasiment le seul parmi 200 mille
américains alors il le soleil commence à
être un peu haut
ils ont bu commence à boire un peu de
bière donc on hésite quand même à dire
qu'on est pour l'europe parce qu'ils
sont extrêmement patriotes très très
fiers de leur pays et ce qui était
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que il ya
des joueurs britanniques qui défendent
les couleurs de l'europe et ils sont
vraiment à fond pour le rock donc ça
fait plaisir de retrouver aussi les
joueurs britanniques dans cette ambiance
vous ne regrettez pas d'être la ryder
cup c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire extraordinaire et puis
vraiment on se réjouit de l'avoir
pendant deux ans en france chez nous
j'espère qu'on sera qu'on sera à la
hauteur
mais pour le passage de témoin justement
côté délégation française il y avait
tout même quelques officiels
oui effectivement wilfried le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
avait son stand à l'entrée du golfe at
the time paul hermitage le responsable
directeur du golf nationalité présent il
y avait également le président de la
fédération française du golfe gens nous
charron et son équipe et il y avait
également à saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
délégation saint quentin en yvelines
avec le président de l'agglomération à
michel laugier
ce dernier a pris quelques notes en vue
de l'organisation en france il était au
micro de tv fil 78
ils sont très bien préparés tout ça a
été vraiment très très bien organisée je
dois dire que je suis surpris mais il ya
beaucoup d'enseignements à tirer les
bogdanoff deux mots qui vont nous servir
dans deux ans à saint quentin en
yvelines
l enjeu est important du point de vue
économique aussi c'est un business
énorme plus de 150 millions de dollars
seront engrangés seulement sur les sites
pendant les trois jours de compétition
sur le site 1 sur le golfe selon les
chiffres donnés par les organisateurs en
voyait les visiteurs vont boire entre 5
et 10 litres de boissons et le panier
moyen d'un américain serait de 100 $
dans les boutiques et vous allez être
gâtés wilfrid je vous ai ramené quelques
échantillons un p'tit caribou on voit
avec marc et ryder cup asia times mais
il est très mignon et y coûte 14 dollars
cas voilà un corner de là je vérifie
tout a évidemment pu enlever les primes
effectivement être historique pour le
groupe trouvé que la stac bien 14,9 en
notes de frais hier soir on a eu
également on a également le maillot de
la ryder cup portés par les joueurs qui
coûtent lui 60 dollars c'est un peu plus
cher
voilà pas fait dédicacer je n'ai pas
fait dédicacer par michael jordan
j'ai égalé j'ai également les chats pour
paul hiver c'est pas mal voilà 30 dollar
aussi donc on comprend vite que ça monte
facilement 100 dollars d'où le panier
moyen est le petit bal voilà la petite
balle de golf c'est le best-seller on
peut le dire de du golf the times tous
les américains quasiment en amp rien par
contre ceux qui drape aux îlots
distribué à l'entrée donc ça pour le
coup ça c'est gratuit à 7 et gratuit
c'est un mois c'était gratuit voilà
impact économique important vous avez
parlé de l'impact économique sur le golf
avec les produits dérivés qui sont
vendus il ya aussi tous les commerces
alentours qui en profite oui il ya
également comme vous disiez des dollars
engrangés en dehors des communes
avoisinantes nous allons écouter à
michael deux ânes un habitant qui a loué
sa maison pour la compétition yak et qui
a également fait taxi pendant les trois
jours pour mener l supporters je
travaille en dehors de la ville ça
n'affecte pas vraiment mon travail mais
je suis également aux conducteurs de
hubert et je fais des airbnb dans ma
maison j'ai deux occupants actuellement
et je vais gagner beaucoup d'argent ce
week-end
soraya oui mais oui daphné mad max
thurman et ben swift et il y aura
également des retombées économiques dans
le futur au total plus de 500 millions
de dollars cumulés pourrait être perçue
par le minnesota dans les cinq
prochaines années avec le tourisme
notamment wilfried c'est la fin de cette
chronique ferme le chapitre jsk et on
peut commencer entre ouvrir le livre
pour la ryder cup 2018 enfoncez vous
allez pouvoir récupérer de votre jet lag
vous reposer d'ici à dix et à demain
pour la rédaction d'un journal et puis
en tout cas on vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour le 7-8 sport vous ne
voulez pas je poursuis à l'intérim pour
7,8 force était malaisie on passe aux
résultats à présent
de résultats vous communiquer en
football tout d'abord versailles à
l'issue de son nul contre le meilleur
partout reprend la tête du championnat
de dh versailles qui a pourtant ouvert
le score à la 18ème avec l'égalisation
adverse en seconde période qui est
versailles qui aurait pu prendre plus
d'avancé sur son poursuivant au
classement les ulis battu par bobine et
vous le voyez les ulis n'est qu'à un
petit point en bas de tableau evry et
les lilas n'ont toujours pas remporté le
moindre match en cinq journées
et puis handball féminin montigny s'est
inclinée par très peu d'écart finalement
face à beauvais alors que dreux et
l'entente noisy-le-grand gagny
poursuivre leur sans-faute en trois
journées au classement à présent lésigny
montagne sont 9e avec lui l'une des plus
mauvaises défenses attention à la zone
de relégation avec seulement une
victoire pour le un moment il y avait du
rugby également ce week-end et pour le
rugby club de versailles le début de
saison est compliqué après avoir perdu
leur premier match la semaine dernière
face à mende s'est à nouveau sur une
défaite qu'ils ont conclu hier le
premier match à domicile face à bagneux
retour sur cette deuxième journée de
championnat avec mélanie poker ils ont
résisté jusqu'à la 30e minute ouvrant
même le score sur une pénalité mais avec
un essai en contre de bagneux à la fin
de la première mi temps les versets les
cracks énormément de frustration
on est très très bien sur la première mi
temps et sur la deuxième on perds un peu
les pédales on perd un peu les pieds on
the path conférence mais plus à la faute
il ya plus beaucoup plus d'erreurs mais
du coup
des routes un peu de nombreuses fautes
de main la défaillance du buteur et un
deuxième essai marqué là aussi en contre
par l'adversaire la descente en division
d'honneur est difficile pour les
versaillais n'est pas en confiance la
descente dans l'année dernière de
fédérale 3 en honneur fait que les
joueurs n'ont pas trop confiance en eux
et doute aussi et encore une fois ce qui
fait que l'on marque pas les points
qu'on a remarqué et derrière on se met à
douter de trois petites fautes de ne pas
et c'est l'adversaire qui score alors
que c'est nous qui produisons tous je
cois score final 3 à 17 2 échecs en deux
matchs pour les hommes d'alain jamin
mais l'équipe ne baisse pas les bras
pour les joueurs ce sera la dernière
défaite à domicile
c'est fait les cougars sont de retour en
d1 l'équipe de baseball de montigny le
bretonneux a remporté à domicile le
championnat de deuxième division
dimanche face à saint-just il aura fallu
cinq rencontres entre les deux équipes
pour se départager cinq matchs sur
plusieurs journées
c'est seulement le dimanche en fin
d'après midi que les locaux se sont
imposés face aux deux filles dunks
dernier match néanmoins à sens unique
avec ce score de 21 à 11 c'est le
troisième titre de d2 de l'histoire pour
montigny le bretonneux
déjà victorieux en 98 et en 2008 rendez
vous donc au printemps prochain pour le
début de saison et pour on l'espère se
faire une place durable à l'étagé
supérieur on passe à la gendarme
coup d'oeil sur l'agenda du week end
avec tout d'abord samedi 8 octobre la
deuxième édition du run and bike a
plaisir à rendez-vous pour promouvoir le
sport dans l'un des espaces naturels
protégés des yvelines les coureurs sont
invités à participer à cette course à
deux sur le vélo l'autre à pied
et puis dimanche 9 le lendemain si vous
avez encore un peu de force vous pourrez
participer au marathon relais organisé
par le club
ekiden une course à pied de plus de 42
km par équipe de six relayeurs c'est à
la base de loisirs à l'île des loisirs à
partir de 9 heures merci de nous avoir
suivis pour cette hebdo est dédié aux
sports lundi prochain vous retrouverez
michael et demi d'euros très bonne
semaine